hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today we're writing a sudoku solver
for another leak code hard interview
problem
in case you're not familiar sudoku is a
puzzle game played on a 9x9 grid
you have to fill in the blanks so that
every row every column
and every block group of three by three
cells
has all of the numbers one through nine
exactly once
we're given that the board that we take
into this function is going to be a
valid board with a unique solution
furthermore we are meant to modify the
board we're supposed to solve the board
rather than return a copy which is
solved
first things first let's write a main
function which does at least one test
case
so here i take in the board represented
as a
big character array and here is the
expected answer
that we're supposed to get then i create
a solution class which is really only
needed for lead code problems in a real
code base
this would just be freestanding
functions but in any case i
create the solution class i print out
the initial board
i print out what i'm expecting i do the
solve and then print out whether or not
it did it correctly so that's at least
one test case
i've written this function it's very
straightforward just to convert
this flat board into a vector of vectors
and this little function just to print
out the board
after compiling and running it we can
see that we can print out the initial
board the expected board
and then our solution hasn't done
anything so of course it doesn't match
i think sudoku is a classic example of a
recursive backtracking
problem where the most obvious thing to
do is
look at the possibilities for what moves
can be made try one
randomly or try the first one or try all
of them and then recursively
solve the problem that way so the real
challenge for this problem is to decide
how do i store the information well
every row column and the three by three
sub blocks need to have all the numbers
one to nine
so for each row column and cell i'm
going to keep track of
which numbers have already been used
i've decided to do this using arrays of
bit sets a bit set is similar to a
standard set
except it lets me store all nine
elements
in basically a single integer the way
that it does this is effectively by
using an integer and using the first
say nine bits of that integer to
represent
whether i have a true or false value in
that location
so if the bit at the zeroth index the
first bit
is set then i'm using that to represent
that one
has already been used this is especially
useful because i can compute
set operations on bit sets by using very
primitive math operations like
for instance i can compute the union of
two bit sets just with the
or operator i'm effectively just oring
the underlying integers which
are made up of those bits the next step
is to loop over the given board
and mark out all the integers that were
already given to us
i loop over the rows and columns and
then if i see something which is not a
blank
then here's what i do i convert the
digit to an index for the bit set
and then for the given row column and
cell
i set the given index as being true
present i did also write this little
function getcell to compute
which cell i'm in given the row and
column then i just give all the
information i've collected so far
to this solve function which we're going
to write which is going to do all the
heavy lifting and the recursion and such
the purpose of the row and column starts
here is to tell the algorithm
where to start basically it should
assume that
anything before this row and column
start
has already been solved and to just
progress forward
and of course by before or after i'm
referring to an order where you go
left to right and then top to bottom the
first thing that i want to do is find a
position that's a blank
something that i can fill in finding the
next empty position is pretty
straightforward i just
loop through and check to see if it's a
blank
and otherwise i keep getting the next
row and column where here we see the
implementation of what the next row and
column is
it's just a little bit of math modulus
trickery
it's pretty straightforward the return
value of next empty position
is either a location that has a blank
for me to fill in
or it's off the board so i can use this
as my base case
if everything has been solved up to row
9 then there's nothing more to do
and that's a solution note here that 9
is one index past
the last actual row the next thing i do
is compute which numbers have already
been used
in the current row column or cell
that's what this line does so remember
each of these things is a bit set
so i am oring these sets together the
result is all the numbers that have
already been used
at this point in the code there must be
a dot at the current location
so if everything has been used then
there's nothing i can use to fill in
that dot
and so we return false otherwise we loop
over all the possible digits and if that
digit has not been used already
then we start the recursive backtracking
so here's what i do i take the digit and
put it
on the board then i mark it as being
used in the corresponding
row column and cell then i recursively
solve the problem
i'm using the return value of solved to
indicate whether or not
solve succeeded if the solve is true
that means
i was able to complete the board and
find the unique solution
after making the guess that i made
otherwise
solve returned false and so i need to
undo that guess
so i unmarked that guess from the row
column and cell and then move on to the
next guess
if none of the guesses succeed then
importantly i need to
reset the current location to a blank
and then say
this failed i wasn't able to complete
the board given the current
stuff that's in the board this allows me
to backtrack
up and potentially give another guess at
an earlier stage
and that's pretty much it back up here
in the main solve sudoku function
i also want to point out that in a real
code base i would definitely want to
check the return value whether the final
solve worked
but in this case we're given that any
input is going to have a unique solution
so we don't need to check it
okay so i compiled it and ran it and you
can see that
with the initial looking like this and
the expected looking like this
we do indeed find that we have a success
and our algorithm was able to
successfully solve the sudoku
all right i went ahead and submitted it
and we saw that the run time was four
milliseconds faster than
about 98 percent and less memory usage
than about 96 percent
so pretty good that's all i have for
this episode if you liked it
be sure to tell your friends subscribe
and don't forget to
slap that like button an odd number of
times see you next time